it's cool it was a fun season it was
eventful you know obviously you've been
seeing the promos out there you know got
a little got a little handsy with Connor
a little yeah why do you push your face
like that I don't know it was it was an
interesting move I kind of liked it you
know it was pretty cool you know I was
like oh bunch of the face all right I
like it yeah well and also also too it's
in the heat of competition I mean say
what you want about Connor Connor you
know he's he's a competitor he wants to
win now he wants to win every single
fight he wants to win the show he wants
to beat me later this year
um so of course the ups and downs of The
Ultimate Fighter experience you know you
got the fights going on he's you know
he's in Vegas for four weeks five weeks
I'm in Vegas we're away from where we is
home if you will you're living on the
road there's all and you've got a camera
in your face all the time wearing a
microphone the whole time it's it's a
different experience as you know but
yeah I mean it was a lot of fun